welcome back to cbs mornings as students
start heading back to the classroom many
will find there are too few teachers to
greet them the country has at least 280
000 fewer teachers in before the
pandemic and listen to this number 72
percent of school districts nationwide
did not have enough applicants to fill
all of their open teaching positions
it's a story we've been following very
closely and joining us now as u.s
education secretary miguel cardona to
bring us up to date good to see you mr
secretary first is the number as bad as
we are hearing that it is and what's
being done to address it
yes good morning and uh thanks for
having me
yes it is you know across the country
parents students educators are filled
with joy to return to school but in too
many cases uh there's a shortage of
teachers and um we we know this to be
true this was true before the pandemic
but it's worse now
that's why we're calling on all
educators all leaders to
use the american rescue plan dollars to
provide incentives to get teachers into
the classroom or bring back retired
teachers without any penalty to their
benefits those are some short-term
solutions that we are seeing that's
working across the country we're also
seeing long-term solutions like grow
your own programs or high schools
creating programs that are connected to
colleges to make sure that the students
of today are the teachers of tomorrow
yeah but you've also got other problems
mr secretary it seems that teachers that
are on the job everybody i know either
knows a teacher as a teacher in the
family tony's mom as it was a teacher my
sister's a teacher my wife was a teacher
nate's wife was a teacher and all the
teachers talk about burnout the burnout
levels are off the charts yeah what do
you think needs to be done to address
that or change that
of course look if we're serious about
addressing the teacher shortage issue we
must address the teacher respect issue
and what that means is providing
competitive salaries
that means improving working conditions
for teachers across the country and
listening right including their voice
and this reimagining of schools
working conditions do matter
as do competitive salaries it's sad we
have teachers who have a master's degree
that have to drive uber on the weekends
to make ends meet that's unacceptable in
the united states
mr secretary the president and the
future of america depends on public
education that's been true for a long
time it'll continue to be true are you
worried when you hear that there are
schools in missouri and other states
that are relying on military veterans
who don't have a teaching degree uh
other schools dropping down to four days
a week for funding and staffing reasons
are you concerned that that could damage
this important part of the future of the
country
i'm very concerned
that we
are not addressing this the way we know
it should be addressed
as i mentioned before competitive
salaries better working conditions and
teacher voice
we have the tools this year thanks to
the
american rescue plan dollars we have
funding available to support this but we
also need states and local districts to
think about how they're funding
education and increased funding with the
same level of urgency that the president
did
mr secretary speaking of money the
student loan pause is ending at the end
of the month will the white house extend
it
yes uh it is uh
scheduled to end at the end of this
month while i don't have an announcement
here today i will tell you that we're
having conversations daily with the
white house and uh boroughs will know
directly and soon from us when a
decision is made
what's the holdup if you don't mind me
asking
well you know again you know i can't get
into the conversations that we're having
daily but i will tell you that from day
one the president has been very clear
about making sure we're uh leading with
students first right and we've been
proud of the uh 29 28 billion dollars in
loan forgiveness up to this point and
the policies that we've changed to fix a
broken system so uh we recognize
americans are waiting on that and we're
going to be uh communicating with them
as soon as we can
can i ask you about teacher salaries
again because everybody always says
teachers need to make more money they
should be paid i don't know anybody who
disagrees with you but that never
changes so what is it going to take for
teachers to make more money in this
country who do we need to tell who do
you need to call what do we need to do
look remember during the omicron surge
where
our schools were closed because our
educators had to quarantine
yes remember the disruption that that
caused across our communities across our
country
let's not go there again we're at the
doorstep of a crisis and if we're not
taking this seriously if that wasn't a
warning that we need to really lift the
profession and
pay them competitive salaries especially
when the job market is what it is then
we're we're missing an opportunity here
so but who makes governors
who makes their decision well state
education funding right state education
funding is is the place to start the
federal government makes up about 10
percent of education funding in general
look at the increases that we put in it
not only with arp but in our yearly
budget i want the same level of urgency
from governors and from uh county and
city leaders across the country
yeah
it's not only pay either it's uh freedom
to teach a lot of teachers feel that
they are in these very narrow lanes
being watched very closely and it's a
dangerous profession to be a part of
that's part of a longer conversation
though secretary cardona thank you very
much